hi so usually when i have to start
writing papers i procrastinate for about
a week telling my professor that i have
already started writing and that
everything is coming along whereas in
reality i'm just kind of putting it off
until the end but when i actually do
start writing i'm fairly fast and over
the last few years i learned some tips
and tricks that really helped me to
speed up my writing process so hi i'm
charlotte fraser a second year phd
student in computational neuroscience
and today i want to talk a little bit
about the paper writing process and if
you're a student or a phd student or a
researcher to help you speed up your
process and make everything a little bit
easier i also have some golden tips that
really for me made a huge difference in
how fast i write my papers so stay tuned
for that so first things first before
you start writing you need to have three
things ready and the first one is that
you need to have your topic your
question or your conclusion fully clear
for yourself so before you even start
writing you kind of need to have in your
mind the goal of why you are writing
this paper so what is the conclusion you
want to get your audience to what are
the most important results such that the
red line throughout your paper is really
clear the second thing is if you are
writing a technical paper i would
recommend to have ninety percent of your
results fully ready so have the figures
have the tables have all the little p
values and everything clear and ready
and i say ninety percent because if you
are a researcher or you're doing some
research you know that nothing is ever
100 ready so if it's 90 ready that is
fine so do your final analysis before
you even start writing and then the
third thing is the literature review so
if you are a little bit prepared you
should have already read most of the
literature that should be referenced to
words in your paper so if you haven't
done this still i would take a day for
example or a couple of hours to go to
the top 10 or top 20 most important
papers in your field or for your paper
such that you can write a few bullet
points and already note them down in
your paper because if you have to do
this whilst writing you lose a lot of
time looking up all the references and
seeing where to go so then it's day one
usually when i start writing and
everything in total is five days and the
first thing of course you do is to open
your favorite editing software and in
science two are used one is word of
course and the other is latex so i
really like latex because it's this
scientific editing software and you can
easily put in formulas but i do have to
say a lot of journals kind kinda don't
really like cloudtech that much so if
you have to submit it to a journal they
sometimes change the formatting and this
can be a huge hassle so if you're gonna
submit your paper i would perhaps
suggest word and it's also easier when
other people want to comment on certain
parts of your paper or you have multiple
authors because in word you can just
easy on the side leave a few comments
and this is harder in latik but yet pick
your favorite one then the next thing
you have to think about is the audience
and the journal you want to submit to so
usually before you start writing your
paper you already have the audience
clear so if for example you're writing
for a class that could perhaps be your
professor or your fellow students but if
you're submitting your paper to a
journal think before you start writing
which journal you probably want to
submit to because then you can know what
kind of formatting this journal prefers
or what they would like to see more more
results or more methods and you can kind
of format your paper a little bit more
towards that specific journal then i
usually start making the outline and the
outline consists of the introduction the
methods the results the discussion and
finally the conclusion i already put in
the results all the little figures i
found all the tables etc i also put in
everything from the literature review in
the right sections such that i don't
have to refer back to that later and i
usually make a skeleton of all the
points i want to say i have to say this
part is probably the hardest to make a
good clear outline but the more time you
spend on your outline the easier the
writing becomes but if you don't have
that much time i would recommend to do
it in about an hour to hour just a full
dump of everything you kind of want in
your paper and then the writing process
becomes a lot easier so then usually on
day two i really start writing so the
first two sections i write are the
methods and the results so the methods
section is relatively easy to write as
it is on the work you have performed so
just think about all the steps you took
and go over your lab notes and or code
and put in all the relevant mathematics
then for the results just like the
method section it's relatively
straightforward because you have the
results already so you just need to
describe them in a little bit more
detail and put in the correct figures
then usually on day three i write the
introduction and discussion so the
introduction should give the reader
enough information to understand your
results but not too much to write an
entire book work on the field so i would
recommend if you struggle with writing
the introduction to read other papers in
your field that have a good introduction
and then see how they structure their
different points and then kyla followed
the same format then for the discussion
i would try to write a paragraph for
each point you want to make so usually
in the discussion it's a little bit more
interpretation of the results it's
usually also a little bit some choices
that you made on getting the results
that are perhaps a little bit
controversial and perhaps it also
contains a few of your future plans so
yeah then it's the editing process and
for the editing process of course you go
over everything you wrote already so if
you made a really rough draft that's
fine you can just go over everything you
wrote and edit it afterwards and one tip
i have already is not to edit whilst you
write so editing really should be its
own separate process otherwise you're
writing something and then editing it
again and then writing it again and that
can take endless so then i want to give
you seven tips that really have speeded
up my writing process and hopefully will
help you a lot so the first thing i
always do is i have a reference manager
so reference manager allows you to
reference papers from across the web in
an easy manner so you have zotero and
mentally and at the moment i use
mentally and i'll show you how i use it
so here i have all the papers that i've
used for my paper and then when i want
to reference it there is a plugin in
word that you can easily use and then
you can just press that plugin and
implement your little zotero reference
or you can also in latex they allow you
to copy the bib text so you can just put
that in your logic reference file then
another thing i would really recommend
if you have a longer time period to
write is to write at really set points
in the day because i think writing is
something we easily forget so for
example if you are a morning person i
would take two hours in your morning and
really make that time for writing and
then if you are in the flow you can
decide to continue writing for a little
bit longer and then thirdly i would
continuing on that note i would use
pomodoro sometimes so i'm in general
sometimes a fan of pomodoros with
certain tasks but it's mostly i use
pomodoros as a jumpstart to get into
flow so if i really procrastinate on
something i set up pomodoro for 25 30 40
minutes and then if i'm afterwards if
it's going well i can continue writing
but if it's not going well i can take a
break of around five minutes then the
fourth tip i have is if you really get
stuck on a certain paragraph and you
don't know how to write it i would
sometimes narrate it so i have on my
phone my google docs document and
sometimes i my fingers are just not
really working or it's not really
flowing and then speaking out loud what
i want to write sometimes gets me
unstuck because when we say something
out loud it's sometimes easier to see
exactly what we are thinking then my
fifth tip kinda on this note is to also
present it to a few people if you have
the chance so for example if you have a
roommate around you can kind of grab
them and ask them to listen to how you
wrote your paper so sometimes i would go
over with a roommate how i structured my
paper and kind of explain them in words
how i did it because usually when you
try to really explain to someone that's
on a similar level as you you can see
the faults in your own thinking and
where you need to elaborate a little bit
more then my sixth tip i usually also
co-write i really like co-writing
personally because writing can be quite
a lonely process so if you have a friend
that's in a writing process you can join
with them in a cafe for example but also
if you don't have friends lying around
that are writing at the moment i also
like these kind of online zoom calls
where people co-write together so you
can find them if you just google
co-writing sessions soon you can find
these kind of calls and i sometimes
really like this because it's kind of
motivating to see other people doing the
same things as you are doing and then
finally once you've written the entire
paper one thing i always recommend to do
is to send it out to as many people as
you know so don't only send it to your
professor but also send it to your
friends for example if they want to read
it or fellow lab mates at etc because
everyone can have a new perspective of
what you have written and this can
really aid you in getting the most
perfect paper ever so these were my tips
and tricks and if you have any tips for
me i would love to hear them so put them
down in the comments below i also made a
video on how to read papers faster so if
you're in the writing process i think
that can also greatly benefit you and
otherwise see you next week bye